you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
cristiano for guerras the woman who
brokered the landmark
2015 paris climate agreement tells sky
news
the uk needs to follow the example of
the united states in tackling climate
change u.s climate envoy john kerry
is in china for climate talks ahead of a
key summit of world leaders next week
and why the uk's woodlands are under
threat from our changing climate
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions this show aims to take you to
the heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come now we've spoken already on the
show about our data dashboard and in
particular
this number here now this shows how much
human activity
has warmed the planet since the
industrial revolution and you can see
it's ticking up every single second
now the aim is to keep that to well
below
2 degrees preferably at 1.5 degrees
celsius
now 196 parties signed up to that in the
paris agreement
in 2015 the most important global
commitment to tackle climate change
and the person who oversaw those
negotiations and the agreement that
followed
is cristiano fergueres as the executive
secretary of the united nations
framework convention on climate change
she was instrumental to the success of
the cop 21 summit
and the paris agreement later this year
nations are due to gather in glasgow for
cop 26 the most significant summit since
paris
because all countries have been asked to
submit their new
long-term goals to cut emissions today
the conference's president alok sharma
told mps the uk is working hard to
ensure that it can go ahead
despite the covert 19 pandemic
earlier i spoke exclusively to cristiano
ferguerres and started by
asking if the uk is doing enough to cut
greenhouse gas emissions
it's very important to differentiate two
roles that the uk is playing
at the same time first of all alex
sharma is the incoming
cop president and as such he cannot
take a uk position he needs
actually to detach himself if you will
from the uk position
and from what the uk does to be able to
be
the correct and neutral
cop president that he needs to be he is
doing
a brilliant job of that on the side of
that
is the uk government different than the
role of the cop
presidency and the uk government is
currently
in process of struggling frankly to
align
all of the policies that are in the
energy sector in the transport sector in
all of the sectors
that they need so what do you think
needs to change
about the uk's policies the uk needs
actually um to take a look at what the
united states is doing we had four years
of darkness around climate change in the
united states and
what the united states has done now is
not just dovetail
itself into where the world is on
climate change
but actually take a step forward and
give
a very very clear monday to all agencies
to all departments
that they are to do their domestic job
but
they need to do it through the lens of
climate change
so the united states has actually come
from behind
to the front it is today the only
country
that is having an all of government
approach to climate change
that is something that the uk but also
every other country can
and should emulate individuals in the uk
for example might say
look at china it's responsible for a
quarter of all emissions
any individual decision i make here is
going to make
no difference so why should i well it is
true that china currently
has uh has uh one quarter of emissions
but
let's remember the historical
responsibility that the uk
has having been the birthplace of the
industrial revolution
uh which is exactly what got us into
this situation to begin with
that is why it is so important that the
uk has actually
uh engaged already years ago in phasing
out of coal
and moving toward renewable energies
that's why it's so important
that the uk has assumed a net zero
target
in its national law because the uk
understands
that they need to change the course now
individuals
are a very important part of that
because
we collectively as individuals but
collectively
we represent demand in the economy and
so when we
as individuals demand clean
efficient non-polluting transport
then corporations take note and provide
that
when we as individuals demand
non-emitting food that is better for our
bodies
and better for planetary health
corporations take note
and develop more options
that are with plant-based protein
when we as individuals demand cities
that are actually organized for
pedestrians for humans and not
necessarily for cars bridges and roads
then urban planners take note and make
the necessary changes
and you can see our full interview with
christiana ferguerrez on sky news's
youtube channel
and you can hear more from her on our
weekly podcast climate cast
that's out this friday and you can find
it wherever you normally get your
podcast from
now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and an
environmental engineer is launching a
legal challenge to the government's
decision to exclude
waste incinerators from its post-brexit
emissions scheme
georgia eliot smith claims the decision
is at odds with the uk's target
to achieve net zero emissions by 2050.
over 11 million tons of waste was
incinerated in england
in 2019
[Applause]
norway has asked brazil to show that it
can reduce deforestation after
brazil asked them to resume donations to
help preserve the amazon rainforest
norway had been one of the biggest
donors to preventing and monitoring
rainforest destruction
but they froze their payments after a
surge in deforestation
since president jaya bolsonaro's
election in 2019.
meanwhile the eu has been named as the
second largest importer of tropical
deforestation according to the wwf
latest figures from 2017 show it was
responsible for 16 percent of
deforestation associated with
international trade
only china was responsible for more at
soy palm oil and beef were the products
imported into the eu
that were the biggest contributors
a national weather service station in
massachusetts which monitors atmospheric
conditions has been abandoned over fears
it could fall into the atlantic ocean
until recently the research station in
cape cod was around a hundred feet away
from the cliff edge
but a series of storms last year
accelerated local erosion
and european bison could help combat
forest
fires associated with climate change the
species went extinct in spain
10 000 years ago but are now being
reintroduced to the country to help
clear forests of fire-fuelling
undergrowth
the fires have been associated with the
climate crisis as well as declining
sheep herding
which traditionally helped to clear
forests
u.s climate envoy john kerry has arrived
in shanghai for talks with his chinese
counterpart
that's all ahead of a virtual summit of
world leaders which president joe biden
will host next week on earth day
now china is the world's biggest
polluter and today new analysis has been
published showing which countries
generated the most
power from coal last year now in terms
of electricity generated by coal
china leads the way with 4630
terawatt hours that puts them at the
very top so here are the top 10
countries
with india next then the united states
and japan all the way down to
australia in 10th place now the uk
doesn't even make the top 25 countries
but look how big the gulf is
between china and the rest of the world
and in fact if you added up everyone
else in the top 10
you'd get just over half of china's coal
generated
electricity and that's one of the
reasons why engaging with china on the
issue of climate change is such
a priority for john kerry so let's bring
in our correspondent mark stone who's in
washington
so mark what can john kerry hope to
achieve with these talks in china
well i think a key achievement will be
getting uh chinese president xi jinping
to actually attend the virtual summit
at the earth day summit next week he
hasn't yet confirmed that he will do so
so
clearly if john kerry can can work his
diplomacy
to ensure that the chinese president is
there that itself
will be a coup don't forget that
chinese-american relations generally at
the moment
are very very bad and so the fact that
john kerry has managed to make this
visit
is in itself an achievement the chinese
are very very aware that they don't or
very wary of
of being lectured to by other countries
about what they see as as internal
issues things like hong kong
and others but i think the advantage for
john kerry here is that he can say look
this isn't an internal issue climate
change
is a global issue and he is not
lecturing to the chinese because he can
also say
we the americans are as bad or almost as
bad as you are the chinese so this is a
collective problem
that we need to engage on so i think the
americans are framing this as a separate
issue yes we have differences elsewhere
but on climate change we're all in this
together mark thank you
the uk's woods and trees could be
approaching a crisis point due to
climate change
a report from the woodland trust says
the uk needs to plant
many more trees if we're to save our
woodlands and the creatures that live
there
our reporter melania vesselinovich has
the story
[Applause]
britain's woods are places filled with
magic but this fragile habitat is under
threat
land development climate change and
pollution are encroaching on it
and scientists say consequences could be
dire
we could start to see species
extinctions from some of our woods
but also just the experience that people
have in woodlands is going to be much
less rich
so you're going to go into woodlands
you're not going to be able to see all
the spring flowers
anymore you won't be able to hear the
birds anymore a new report by the
woodland trust says only seven percent
of native woods in the uk are in a good
condition
and nearly all exceed thresholds for
nitrogen pollution
a by-product of farming but keeping the
woods healthy is key to the future of
the planet
this ancient wood is more than 400 years
old and
trees here capture carbon and store it
for centuries
they could be one of our greatest allies
in the fight against climate change
trees and plants are second only to the
ocean at generating oxygen
they actively sequester the carbon
dioxide from our atmosphere
and gather it and store it within their
bodies
this is really really important towards
the fight against greenhouse
gas emissions experts say we need to
quadruple the amount of trees we are
planting
to give nature a chance of recovery if
we don't
they say there's much to lose
milena vasilinovic sky news
and that's everything from us on the
daily climate show for today next time
can a food supplement for cows really
reduce the amount of methane they
produce
find out at the same time tomorrow see
you then
[Music]